walk him to this video playing
greenhaven from the US went 46 maybe
going for Kings Indian later yeah
packings in yen dismiss law system um I
think back then I went with this often
be five I wonder sometimes you can play
be five here is this a position where
you can let's try this light takes 94 is
serve is some compensation and a 6a for
him and he's got the bishop on g5 so
maybe this is possible ok trying to
prepare a form
let's see I want to play maybe cannot
make it I can I do that Queen a 52 to be
for you I want to activate the Queen us
as much as possible would be funny if
you have I get in queen before i take
the bishop on edge form it's not unknown
to to be opening some dives okay so
let's see my queen is not getting
trapped isn't it Queen a three UK 3i can
take b5 rook a rugby three I can take on
c4 and probably sacrifice the Queen yeah
I thought I can sacrifice the Queen a B
or is he just playing hxb after that
maybe oh thanks no a bee look be three I
take on c4 look before that's it's a
massive compensation come on come on
this looks like a very good compensation
maybe maybe you can play night eight to
one this one now that's ambitious but
maybe there may be right I don't know
Knight b6 keeps everything attack down
I thought that my compensation would be
good because when i get get d 5 or get
night before and i have have this be to
ponder here can place you three may be
195 takes Knight c3 poo very tough c3 I
don't like let's let's do that probably
the computer will laugh at me after
that's afterwards but from a human
perspective this is this is an
interesting interesting way to play ok
Knight takes he's got green d 5 mm I
didn't see that beforehand and that's
not good
now you've got queen dee three moves
like that I have a Bishop f5 them now
maybe it's still not clear check
Bishop a 60 g 5 first I don't know if he
threatening this on e 7 ok I'm going to
do this it weakens my king but don't I
cannot really care about this too much
ok allows me to take them immediately
and this wants to king of three ik i
have G far though may be very tough to
blame for both sides actually
so Bishop chicks I guess Bishop takes
that I can use the pawn cm ok
I need to retreat you keep keep this
protected
always amazed how quickly they play this
kind of positions like like it's it's
it's right out of kindergarten the
should eh
look see one that is going to take your
time morning I'm done during the bloody
rook ah out of this position yeah great
that's really this is so annoying this
guy's playing all moves instantly in a
super complicated position and it's
probably screwing up tremendously ax
then I'm blundering the look rue k2 is
just winning for black of course minus
five yes that's right nah this is
annoying yeah check i stopped moving the
pieces but he I'm just winning you with
rook c2 it's over and then I fire then
you can resign just like that okay I
mean the position was totally unclear
and he just plays instant moves Bishop
f4 he is already bringing four black
yarn gem dad's always it's always very
disappointing when you when you try some
interesting concept but I'm not there
not sure if it's if it's good I mean
let's see what what the engine says it
yeah it gives a blackguard clear
advantage ship remarkable with she takes
p3 though this is easier to play yeah
the problem was this is also good but
the problem was with g5 that it is it is
very complicated of course my king is
also getting weak and yeah him it is
just a winner amazing check this is also
with B 3 is minus 4 yeah but the King
position is still is still a problem
yeah I really cannot say I did anything
wrong here besides here f5 f5 was just
yeah rook f6 in fact I can still play
whoopsie to check ah can still play
chess and and then this is then that
said he does not even have a check in
this position oh man okay I need new
game ah thanks for watching